all right welcome to the final day of
the workshop
um thanks for making it uh this morning
we have a slight change in schedule as
you might have noticed uh we're shifting
all the talks
um up by one unfortunately video could
not make it this morning
um so that means we'll be ending early
and we'll have only two talks after
lunch
um in these talks uh are very exciting
to me um some of these are some of those
influential papers on my research in the
last few years
um in my thinking about RL and time
varying Bandits
and it really is these talks speak a lot
to the hybrid theme of this Workshop you
know somewhere between adversarial and
stochastic
um and also you know starting to
question
um how accurate you actually need your
models to be
um and so first up we have chanyu Wei
from uh he has PSG at USC and uh he's
going to start it as assistant professor
at University of Virginia
uh and is currently a postdoc
assignments so in his work uh if I'm
correctly is the best paper award at
Colt right
and uh yeah so please take it away
[Music]
for the introduction so the topic today
is optimal Dynamic regret for Bandits
without prior knowledge
so the problem we concern is online
learning which involves the interaction
between a learner and an environment
each round the learner takes an action
and then the environment will have a
feedback to a learner
specifically you consider Bandit
feedback where the feedback is just the
reward of the chosen action
so an example is when a learner is a
recommendation system and their
environment is a user
their their recommender Will May
recommend something to the user and
receive the corresponding feedback
but the recommender does not see the
feedback for those items that it does
not recommend so this is the the
property of the Bandit feedback
and we know that uh the user's
preference will change over time
and what will happen when it's combined
with the Bandit feedback
so we can see this picture
so this is a movie a preference for
movies of the user
and we can see there there are two kinds
of movies and the preference over them
of changes over time
so typically we run when we run a bandit
algorithm we have an exploration in the
beginning and we do exploitation
negative
and in this picture we can see that
because in the exploration phase the
learner finds that a romance movie is is
preferred by the user so it keeps
recommend this movie
but then because the the preference
changes but because it does not the
recommended recommendation system does
not explore the other actions so the
performance will become bad in the later
phase
and what's the solution for this kind of
a problem
obviously we need to sometimes to sample
those actions that looks bad before
because the environment is changing so
you need to detect the change
and we see that there are two kinds of
exploration one is initial exploration
here is extra exploration so in the
initials exploration the goal is to
resolve the uncertainty and there are
some existing principles like Optimizer
interface of uncertainty to do this but
the extra exploration the goal is to
discover the changes
and this will not be uh covered by the
optimism interface of uncertainty
and let's have a closer look at the the
relation between the degree of
non-stationarity I uh that is
the frequency of the changes of the
environment and the amount of
exploration we need
so we see that uh it's like this we if
the environment is stationary we have
some we need some amount of exploration
but when the environment is more and
more non-stationary we need more
exploration
the extra part is called Xbox
exploration
the challenge is that how do you use the
right amount of exploration without the
prior knowledge on the degree of
non-stationarity
if uh if you can now pick the right
amount you may suffer over exploration
or under exploration
and they both hurt the performance
and this is actually a challenging
problem that we will discuss today
uh we first see the motion Band-Aid
problem with non-station energy the
proper information is like this you have
K arms
every time the environment choose a mean
reward Factor mu T then the learner
chooses an arm a t then learner observes
the reward whose expectation is from
community of 80.
and we Define the dynamic regret as uh
like like this
so you can see that we compare the
We compare the reward of the learner
with the best policy or the best arm
every time and see the difference
clearly if the environment is changing
arbitrary arbitrarily this can be linear
in t so we need to have some regularity
quantities to uh to help us Bond the
dynamic regret
one typical quantity is s which is like
uh how how many times the MU T Vector
changes
and the other is B which quantifies the
fine Grand amount of change over time
and it has been shown that the tight
Dynamic regret
a lower bound is like a minimum between
square root St and V 130 to a third
and let's see some results in Prior work
well so this is definitely another
exhaustive list there are much more
papers I just need some some papers that
are more familiar with and I think it's
important
yeah
foreign
a square root St bound is only is
already achievable when you know that
you know s
but if you don't know as uh you can get
as s squared t
and for the V setting if you know V you
can get some bound tight tight bomb
uh so the others are in the unknown case
and so I I may I mean I'll go through
all the all the results but I want to
point out that this is uh by hour at all
it's the first to get a tight Bond
without the knowledge of this and there
are some several other follow-up works
that try to generalize this uh their
framework for multi-ambending to other
kinds of offended problem or
reinforcement learning problems
and actually today
I will spend even more time to explain
the idea of an hour at all then I would
say how to generalize it to other
problems
so uh they actually have two papers the
first is for two arm and then they
generalize it to 2kr
and then we have a paper that
generalized there idea to a wide range
of problems
and there is a recent personal
communication with us that further
generalize our approach so what's the
result of the these two generalization
[Music]
the final results is that
if you uh it's like a reduction from
non-stationary Bandit problem
to a stationary bended problem
so we can have a metal algorithm that
turns this algorithm that works for a
stationary case and turn it into a
non-stationary algorithm and if the
input algorithm is optimal the output
algorithm is also optimal
okay
this is a teaser to get our from get we
familiar with the problem uh which one
is the most difficult to detect
just to give you more information uh the
first is the case is that bad arm
becomes good the second is good arm
becomes bad
and this third is both are changing
the first one yes so uh yeah so when
your initially doing exploration you
will find this is the better arm so you
will keep sampling this red on
and then if you keep do that you will
now notice that the other bad arms
changing becoming best
so for the other two you you don't
suffer this problem so only this one
needs an extra exploration
and okay so but the fact is that you
still need to detect both okay
uh so we'll go to our algorithm but for
Simplicity we'll only discuss a very
simple case there are two arms and the
mean change at most once
and that the initial means are known so
it's like this
uh uh the A and B are no okay but the
change point is unknown
and the amount of change is also unknown
the amount of change is defined as the
maximum between the change of the two
arms
okay
so let's see the template of our
algorithm our algorithm will look like
this but so uh
so this is just again the timeline and
the mean of the arms
um so in our algorithm most of the times
we because we know the initial mean okay
so we almost of the time we will just
pick the arm that is best in the
beginning which is a red arm
but at times we'll uh insert some
something called detection blocks
uh which is indicated by this Yellow
Block so in these blocks we will
uniformly randomly draw the two arms and
the goal is to re-estimate their means
because they may change at some time
okay and if the learner successfully
detects the change you will choose the
arm with the better re-estitative mean
till the end okay because only change
once
okay so this is a very reasonable
algorithm
although we haven't decided whether when
to insert the detection blocks
uh so
so
what what do we what's required for for
a successful detection you can see that
okay there are four detection blocks by
the first three for some reason it does
not succeed
but this the last one is 60. so what
what makes a successful detection uh I
think the first is a easy one the
detection block needs to start after a
change points otherwise it cannot detect
the change the second condition is that
the detection block needs to be larger
than one over C Square recall that c is
the number uh the amount of change
and the reason is that if we want to
estimate the mean up to the accuracy of
C then you need and only need roughly 1
over C Square samples I think this is uh
clear from the confidence inequality
okay so a successful detection block
will have these two uh
property
and our regret we'll have two parts one
I call detection overhead the other is
non-detection penalty so what is
detection overhead
um
so it's just the overhead because you
insert these detections and because you
random draw the arms uh so you suffer
the loss of the bed arm
and non-detection penalty is because
of the delay so
we basically drop red arm
and then before we successfully detect
the change in this part we are still
mostly focused on the red arm so this is
the
non-detection penalty because of a
detection delay and the key of the
algorithm design is to smartly schedule
the detection blocks to balance these
two terms
yeah some trade-off
so let's have a closer view of the
trade-off let's see
okay so this is a challenging case that
we see in the beginning the bad arm
becomes good and we let's see
three different cases
so
the the change is large or change is
small or even small and does not exceed
the original a good arm
so what should what would be a
successful detection look like in the
first case
well because the change is so big
the detection block need not be very
long right because it needs only to be 1
over C Square
so this is good because we don't have
much uh detection overhead
what
uh because the Gap is so big so if you
have a little bit delay it incurs a lot
of regrets so it has a high penalty per
unit delay
Okay so
one is good one is not good and by delay
I mean from a change point to the
beginning of a successful detection
in the second case uh we need longer
detection blocks
that is too small it's smaller
but we have low penalty per unit delay
for a third case there's no need to
detect
if you want to detect you need even
longer detection block but there's no
need to detect it
because you just should keep choose your
red arm then it's okay
so uh so what should be the design of
our detection block
let's focus these are these two case
for the first case
uh what we need is probably a shorter
detection blocks but more frequent
okay because you need to minimize the
delay for the second case
you need longer detection blocks but
more infrequent scheduling
and because we don't know what's the
size of the change so we may need both
so
uh what we want to do is just to
like Superstition just a
do both
and we call that uh because because the
in the detection block what you do is
just a uniform draw the two arms so the
the the overlap doesn't doesn't matter
okay so let's see the more formal
algorithm and again we first assume that
initial reward are known
uh so this is the algorithm okay this is
the algorithm by hour at all okay
uh for each Epsilon Epsilon is like the
target Gap you want to detect and notice
that the smallest
detect is Delta over two yeah the if a
change is smaller than that we don't
care
and
uh with some probability P Epsilon we
will initiate a detection block that is
of links roughly one of us Epsilon
Square okay so you see that
uh when Epsilon is smaller you have less
increase Less in free you have
infrequent
scheduling but it's longer
okay so it's like a correspond to our
previous intuition
uh okay so you allow overlap and then
you just do this scheduling and
uniformly randomly choose an arm if T
lies in any of the detection block you
schedule otherwise you choose the the
better arm in the beginning which is the
red arm in our case
and the detection will is very simple
at the end of every detection block uh
whose length is one over Epsilon Square
you check if the mean has changed more
than Epsilon
a prime and B Prime are the mean
estimation in inside the detection block
uh if so then you you then you find that
the environment has changed then you
switch to the the better arm in your in
your estimation
so this I think this is quite simple
and we we uh like we assuming it's only
changed once
okay uh in if you don't know the if you
don't know the initial mean then the
algorithm will do some extra steps in
the beginning you will draw two arms
uniformly I ran them until uh you
distinguish them and at this phase you
might still face some non-stationarity
so you still need to detect so yeah
there there this part is relatively
easier than the the part here
and the next thing we want to do is to
do the regret analysis for this
algorithm
we want to prove that it has a square
Rooty Dynamic regret
so uh we prove under a special case so
you know the
it may be like the the blue arm is going
down or the red arm is going up or
something but let's just focus on this
and
as we said this is the most challenging
case
and the change point is defined as s and
the this is a successful detection block
the end of is e
and let's assume the change amount is C
and C is larger than Delta
as we say the dynamic regret has two
parts one's detection overhead the other
is non-detection penalty
for the detection overhead it's the the
cost
because you do the detection
so
for this part I calculate the because
for example if in the first
like before the changes
if you don't if you don't do detection
then you just choose the red arm but
because you do some detection so you
sometimes choose the the blue arm
so the like the overhead in the in the
before the change is like Delta times
the total detection block length in
before the change okay
for non-detection penalty we simply
bounded SS because this Gap will be
smaller than C
uh
so the regrets will be upper bounded by
c times
uh the the E minus s
okay no matter what arm you choose this
is the upper bound of the regret okay
so let's bond it
uh so uh in the algorithm we already
choose uh how how frequently we schedule
detection block
and it's you can do the calculation it's
it's expectations like this this is the
probability you start a
detection block of length one over
Epsilon
uh every time
okay
and for the non-detection penalty it's
more we need more carefully so let's
define two parts one is the the
successful detection block links the
other is a delay
the lengths the block length will be 1
over c squared
and what about delay
um so we know that
every time with probability PC we will
start a detection block of lengths one
over C Square so the expected time
between here and here is like one over
PC okay so now you see a trade-off
between like how how do you pick this P
to balance these two terms and it's
chosen the algorithm and you can indeed
calculate them and see they are all
bounded by square root of
the length of the time
so overall you get a square root regret
in this case
yes why do we not need to included
uh yes yes so it's already like included
in this term
um right because
this Gap is at most C
yeah right if after e after e you you
just uh stop run you just pick the blue
arm afterwards
yeah we start because we know it changed
only once so okay
how do you have account for overlapping
detection box oh it doesn't matter
because uh
when overlapping you just simply just
again do a uniform centering over
towards that's better some you sort of
assume that is
important song
yeah this is upper bound so when you
have overlap is
the aggregate the examples in the
detected blocks together or to Target to
detect it within one block
or just one uh
the detection block and after a while
you may initiate another Detective to
add all the samples together like a
aggregate looking together
I think they're just share the samples
and you do everything over it's
original period
within you you only look at the
detection within the block yeah yeah
yeah just yeah right
yeah so what if you think you detected
it but actually you detected the wrong
Advantage oh yes uh detect the wrong
thing you mean uh the high probability
given by both being killed
yeah that's a small probability we will
just make this probably so small so you
don't care
um
that's a very good so that will be like
the next algorithm I would I would say
but this is the element by hour at all
it's actually not okay
foreign
points but it's actually the same
algorithm it doesn't change it uh it I
just changed the last line so uh if if
you detect the change then you restart
the algorithm that's that's all
so
now we need to approve a proof sketch
for this uh for multiple change point
for the same algorithm it will be more
uh complicated
uh so I only give a sketch but again we
assume the initial rewards are known
it's like the initial exploration is
already done and we know about the extra
exploration
so
and their length the interval lengths
are L1 and 2 and so on and we Define CI
as the change of the arm in the interval
I
and the change is compared to the
initial reward so
it's not like comparing this and this
it's always comparing this and the
initial reward that's the change in
interval I
foreign
classify the interval industry classes
the first is called ignorable uh it
means that the change is smaller than
Delta over two again uh in this case
the red the red arm will be better than
the blue arm
so like the L the second universe is
like ignorable because it change is so
small compared to what you can
okay so and the second one is a large
change
but it's its length is uh small so like
Health uh the third interval is like
undetectable and why do I say this is
undetectable uh as I said if you want to
detect a change of order CI then you
need at least this many and these many
samples but the whole interval is even
smaller than that many of samples so
it's undetectable
and the third one is detectable and the
the first and the fourth word are
detectable
and let's define e as the time we
terminate the algorithm and restart
uh detection overhead we will still
bound it and let me just say it's upper
bounded by square root e
or uh about non-detection penalty uh if
it's in ignorable intervals then it's
zero
the penalty in undetectable intervals
are like change
times the length of that interval but
according to the definition of a
undetectable interval this will be
smaller than square root l i
okay yes sorry something they said why
do we uh why can we only restart once
yes
oh okay we only Analyze This algorithm
yeah
uh so after enter uh
so we women sometimes decide to restart
and we will restart uh another same
algorithm I'm doing an analysis that is
only up to this point
yeah if you come from this pump and the
eye is coming over this
before this will start
if you do many many results just Sunday
is over
and the most interesting case is the in
the detectable the regret the penalties
like still like this
um
but
uh because you need a detect you need to
if you want to detect a change for this
interval then you need at least this
many at least this length and you if you
really want to make a successful
detection then you have to initiate a
detection block
uh in this period the purple one
so let me call this delay
and similar for the other
so our repair will be like this
and then okay
this
is smaller than square root LT just by
the the definition of the detectable
and with some proof
uh you sum the liquid up
or you can show that this aggregate you
some of some of this delay
you can show that it's it's upper bound
vascular
yeah I will now go to the details
okay at the end you get this found
there are some uh I think this is the
most interesting uh part in the analysis
if you have you're interested you can
come to me
okay so up to this slide is the
algorithm by Peter our particular and
Runner order
so
okay so now we want to generalize it to
more General problems
so the general form it actually looks
like a bended problem so you have a
policy set environment user mapping in
the beginning
and then you choose a policy and you get
the reward of policy and the dynamic
regret is always comparing with the best
policy
so this can capture a linear bandage
mdps episode mdps or any other problems
uh so as I know there are at least three
papers that already tried to extend
their approach to other settings
um so the first is by them themselves
from two arm to K on
uh if you see this out it's a
it's a very natural extension but you
have you have to maintain a good uh good
armset and bad onset and do arm
elimination from good good set to bed
set and then try to detect the changes
for all arms
so it's kind of complicated
and for the other two uh approaches
the extensions are based on a algorithm
called I love to count Bandits it's for
a contextual Bandit setting but the idea
in these two papers are to maintain the
distribution of our policies and control
variance of the reward estimators
and it's still like uh like tracking the
changes of all policies and using some
optimizing Oracle
but this kind of approach does not is
not applicable to other problems like
that I listed here so we might need to
have some other ideas
so let's rethink about the problem or
the solution
we really need to track every policies
changes in in the uh in KR bande they
try to detect changes for everyone
uh actually the answer I don't know how
it might be yes or no but
uh
we can say that we only need to track
two things the the first is that whether
the best policy reward becomes High and
the other we want to care about is
whether the learner's reward becomes low
this is really the two things you need
to care about
you don't need to explicitly know which
policies are are changing by how much
okay
so uh the second is relatively easy
because you're you're doing your policy
and you know it becomes low and what
about the first how do we track just a
try to track the best policies reward
so let me introduce
a thing that is familiar to you no
regret algorithm
so no regret algorithm in a stationary
environment okay the environment is now
stationary
in the stationary environment the
algorithm ensures that you have a
sublinear regret that's the no
redefinition of uh or it's a no regret
algorithm summation okay so I'm saying
that there's no regret algorithm can
help us
uh help us track the optimal policies
reward
and how do you do that
well if you run a No Regret algorithm in
stationary environment
and you plot your average reward over
time
then I I claim that you can
uh like applaud a confidence interval
where the optimal policies reward lies
in it so what's the upper body and lower
bound
uh the upper bound is given by the
regret guarantee because the regret
guarantee essentially tells you this
so you can plot it upper Bound for f
star
for lower bound because F star is the
best policies reward for concentration
inequality
this cannot be two and their difference
cannot be too negative
okay so you
you plot a confidence interval for f
star
and how do you use this to
well the goal is to use this to build a
detection block
okay how do you do this
uh okay so similar situations before but
now we've
we run an algorithm
that's our original algorithm but for
the detection block we actually just
start a new algorithm
and this is the confidence interval it
built and how do we tell that uh how do
we tell that the
the optimal reward has changed
well because this was originally an
upper Bound for fsor
and this was a lower bound uh if the
environment is stationary but now the
lower bound becomes higher than upper
bound so it means that the the optimal
reward has changed
so this is easy to see and the situation
the picture is very similar to the two
arm case
but now we are much more General and we
can also see an interesting thing uh we
originally run an algorithm and a
detection block because you actually use
the same thing
yeah
so this is the algorithm by again I'm
just showing a previous algorithm
and in their algorithm there's an
initial exploration and extra
exploration part
okay and then for detection they check
if any arm changes
uh in our case
I'm saying that initial exploration and
extra exploration are using the same
algorithm so we we don't need the other
base so uh so we do it very similar
things
um just with some minor change because
we don't want to
uh switch between the
detection blocks so much so we we only
can start the detection block as some
fixed points it's not yeah so but but
the frequency is roughly a similar
difference before and now you can now
overlap between the detection blocks
because they are doing they are
different
algorithms so
uh so but it's this is also similar uh
simple to address
uh so in in this is original scheduling
by their overlap
uh you always choose the smallest links
to execute when they are overlapped and
for a longer when you pause
and the reason is that this shorter one
the goal of the shorter one is to ensure
that you can quickly detect the large
change so you don't want to want it to
be blocked by those
longer detection blocks you need to
quickly detect the larger change
for the detection
as we for every base algorithm that we
execute around t as we said you can
calculate a upper bound and lower bound
we are supposed to be an overbound low
Bound for f star if the environment is
stationary
but if
the it's violated that means f-star has
changed then do restart
in this step we can detect
uh
yeah basically you can detect whether ft
storage or change or becoming better
than before like okay
and the other thing we wanted we still
need to do is to is to detect whether
the learner's performance drops okay but
this is uh again this is relatively
easier and I opened the detail but you
still need to do this step
uh okay then I I say here this is a
combination of my paper with this uh
personal communication with it oh by the
way one is
in uh UT Dallas
okay so what's what's uh what's the
combat combination so I want to remark
this in our uh original paper the
condition for the base algorithm
slightly looks slightly drop stronger
the algorithm needs to Output the
quantity for FG tilt in every round so
that it can ensure two things
if you're familiar with the like
mdp algorithm or Martin Band algorithm
this is exactly the guarantee of a UCB
styled algorithm
okay but what meaning is that you only
need this no regret guarantee with high
probability guarantee if you have this
and you you calculate this activity then
it will satisfy the UCB condition
so it actually means that the no request
condition is the same as equivalent to
the UCB condition
so this make uh the out the reduction
even more General in its appearance
uh okay so at the end I uh
okay so at the end I want to just
comment about so today we only focus on
this hard switching case but if you want
to handle the gradual change case to get
the amount depend on V you need the
basic algorithm to satisfy a slightly
stronger assumption you need to have
regret Bound for a near stationary
environment
uh it's just saying that if you're
if that change in the environment is
small try some quantity then the
algorithms still need to ensure this no
regret guarantee plus this uh
this extra quantity
okay
but this is still minor all the
algorithms you know still satisfied this
condition
and
as a summary
today I talked about three parts
the first part is a the multi-scale
detection
mechanism by RSO they are the first to
solve this where to get a square root St
Bound for Bandits
and our contribution is to have a black
box usage of their idea and we can apply
it to algorithms with USB condition and
unless
meaning proved that no regret condition
applies implies the UCB computation
finally on this last slide
there are some recent development for
this related problem
so we have shown that we have these two
with our with our knowledge of s or V
recent work by
uh Abbasi yeah
proved that
they improved it to uh especially the
number of times based on switch
so it's it's smaller than S
and even recently there's a a paper that
defines a significant shift that's that
can substance all these results
uh so there's an open question
uh can we get this but what is SC SC is
just how many times they regret
comparator changes so all these
quantities are defined on the
environment
like how many times the environment
changes SD is just a
there's a modifying your regret a
comparator sequence how many times a
sequence change the environment can
change arbitrary and clearly this will
subsume all the other results
but there are some results for this
related with this first
uh this is the same algorithm by hour at
all if you know SC then you get this
um at all if you don't notice the and
you're facing up the Universe episode
you get this bomb with a penalty of T
reinforce
and a lower bound an impossibility
results is given by Marvel of Andy March
you cannot get this pump for any Alpha
uh
if you don't know s and you're facing
adaptive adversary
this has a provable gap between the
oblivious and adaptive adversary
and I think the interesting open
question is whether you can get this
pump
without knowing SC and foreign for an
oblivious adversary
so that concludes my talk thank you
are we found questions
[Music]
even uh
if you haven't algorithm that has no
high probability no regret energy
that you can make it work for
enunciation
okay
but it's known as see
so in the original paper it was assumed
that the number of changes is known or
not what do you mean by origin uh like
the hour
2002 paper
obviously exp 3.s so you have to tune
the if you want that's that paper okay
that is 2002 okay very early yeah sure
okay gotcha uh because this this
that you presented doesn't need to know
as all right yeah
um yeah but the S is uh like a larger
font like a layer yeah it's an
agriculture yeah
it seems like the hardware is changed
as far as I heard there's also I
wouldn't like sliding windows or
discounts memory kind of algorithms so
now there's change detection works
better than or
on this so for a sliding window again I
think people cannot figure out how to
set the length of the sliding window so
it always needs to
know how frequent the environment is
okay okay
um
[Applause]